[Music]
driving over here this morning there was
a billboard that says the universe is
expanding but your closet is not so you
know go store your stuff in our storage
facility I would say that that was a
remarkably happy billboard for me to see
because it is correct the universe is
expanding and your closet is not and
this is a misconception that some people
have that along with the expansion of
the universe everything is expanding the
earth and you and so forth in Annie Hall
Woody Allen points out that the universe
is expanding but Brooklyn is not
expanding and he and the Billboard are
right and the person on the street might
not be the expansion of the universe
isn't something that is like pulling
apart everything it's more like the
initial conditions near the Big Bang's
started everything moving apart and
things have been coasting ever since so
the fact that things are moving apart in
the universe the expansion of space is
kind of a leftover from the Big Bang but
once things come together to make a
galaxy or a planet or a closet or
Brooklyn they're not expanding apart
anymore
so we are staying the same size while
the universe is expanding or if you are
expanding it is not because of the
expansion of the universe
you